speaking about horror anime and just the
lack of it one thing I always find
interesting is when there's like a
series that's not a horror series but
then they have like an episode that's
just really [__] terrifying or like
really really scary in itself right
example
um one of the examples that I always
which SpongeBob episode when they get
stuck at the uh their place in Bikini
Bottom when they get like when they go
down the oh the uh yeah
um I've not seen a single SpongeBob so I
I have I have no I have no horse in this
race I have no Horse
no dog says yeah
now one episode that stands out to me is
uh there was an episode of like Ghost in
the Shell
stand-alone complex yeah [__] [__]
insane anime it's basically
cyberpunk before cyberpunk existed
I had a memory I'm sorry didn't we just
say I don't want to finish yeah
it's been so like so much Ghost in the
Shell there's like a plot point where
they find the guy and they're like how
do you have so much money he's like well
I just took every extra Yen that
happened during every Bank transaction
off the top and I was like in my head
I'm like what like every Bank
transaction yeah yeah it would be like
millions of boats yeah yeah just take
one yen from all of them or something or
you would take the like it was so
[__] stupid hey man that's [__]
fine he was like that's how I'm a
billionaire and we're like oh my God I
never thought about that if only I could
do that I could take one dollar off the
top of everybody like one cent right it
was something like yeah yeah one yen
from every bank transfer yeah yeah made
it seem like he was a giga brain dude
I'm so sorry I don't know why I haven't
okay no that was that was that was I
like that episode actually I like that
one too yeah uh but there was one
episode where they were trying to find
the serial killer and I don't know why
the scene always sticks out with me
because the smiling guy not The Smiling
guy there's that was also terrifying
that was all terrifying terrifying there
was a lot of actually pretty scary
because it's such a good [__] series
but there was this one uh episode where
okay so it basically follows like the
whole concept of Ghost in the Shell
imagine cyberpunk that kind of world but
you follow a police squad like a like a
police squad that's basically the core
concept and it's all like episodic kind
of episode so every episode has a
different storyline that's kind of
self-contained uh and then there's one
episode they are looking for this serial
killer and the way that the zero the the
serial killer the serial killers MO is
that he loves to skin his subjects alive
um and
the thing that he does while doing uh
the thing that he does while doing it is
since it's in a cyberpunk-like world
what he does is that he jacks into the
girls uh he he skins girls by the way he
jacks into the girls that he's about to
skin and transmits POV what he's looking
at to the girl's wrestlers not remember
this so what happens is he transmits his
POV to the girl's retinas so the girl
can't close her eyes and he will skin
them alive while the girl is watching
herself being skinned alive live and the
the terrifying thing is they never show
anything in this in in this episode they
never show anything it's just the
description of the crimes itself and
there's one scene where
um they're watching one of the
recordings of the girl being skinned
right and all you see is just all you
hear is just the sound of this happening
the screams and one of the guy running
out and just throwing up and that just
that [__] terrified oh yeah it's the
the fact that it didn't show anything I
think kind of even made it worse right
that was that that that whole episode
has just stuck with me so strongly not
because the content itself is terrifying
but just like the whole idea of that
[__] happening I think yeah as you said
like it's the fact that they don't show
what is happening yeah and they show the
before and the after yeah is like
because like that reminded me as well
like uh like one of those scariest
scenes in uh perfect blue yeah was the
one where uh oh was it perfect world
paprika I forgot which one it was but it
was um it was like a movie yeah it's one
of the Satoshi con films but it's like
the one where like the guy goes into the
elevator
um and there's like a radio just playing
yeah and and I think the concept was
like the killer like leaves behind like
a a radio or some kind of object in it
to like notify that oh he's about to die
yeah and it's This brilliant scene of
like Satoshi Khan not actually showing
the murder happening but he shows the
before of the guy going into the
elevator seeing the radio him getting
terrified and the door closes yeah and
then the next moment is the door opens
and he's already dead yeah right and
it's this idea of like it's not showing
the Gore as it's happening it's showing
like something [__] happened here
yeah but we're gonna leave it up to your
imagination because your imagination is
probably gonna just you know expand upon
the [__] upness yeah which makes it
even more terrifying right and like
that's so hard to do yeah but I feel
like a really good director like saying
like Oshima Moro for uh Ghost in the
Shell yeah yeah so good at doing that
yeah um and yeah because I remember that
scene as well and like like another like
not not scene but another like character
that [__] terrifies me
um Johan from monster
he is by far the best anime villain to
be written he terrifies me and you never
do you ever like really see him do
anything like [__] up like gory or
anything like that but like just I don't
know he throughout all of monster
whether you read the Manga or watch the
anime he is you can feel his presence
everywhere right and I don't know how
the author was able to just convey that
everywhere you just feel his presence
kind of like a ghost and just the his
the idea of him as a character also is
just [__] terrifying that it's it's
kind of like kind of like the [__] that
keeps you up at night it's just such a
good series yeah yeah and that's why
he's the goal the dub is really good as
well yeah the dub is great Johan sounds
terrifying in the job yeah yeah Johan is
terrifying in the dub and what what's
great as well is that even though you as
the series goes on you find out more and
more about his backstory you never find
find out enough that it stops being
terrifying right and it it goes all the
way up until the very last scene the
very last page of the manga I I just I
just remember it because I'm like how
are they gonna end this and you don't
remember it well Conor's not the type of
person that remember something after you
finish watching it we've we've
established this already but it ends it
in the most like
perfect and yet terrifying way where
Johan poses a question I guess and it's
just like okay that just somehow just
tied oh yes everything together and I
know I'm just like this should we watch
70 episodes It's been a long time since
I read the Manga but yeah it makes me
not very very monster
I want to watch ghosts in the show too
because I don't remember anything yeah I
don't remember a lot about ghosts in the
show but I just remember that like it
the only thing I remember is uh in the
latest goes to Michelle in 2045 I think
it was called uh just [__] kusunagi
back flipping up the stairs
which is the [__] most hilarious CG
you've ever seen in your life they made
a new one on Netflix yeah yeah yeah CG
is oh my God her just back flipping up
the stairs is so funny like actually bad
actually about like Attack on Titan
planning everyone yeah micro second of
yeah
was I the only one that found episode
six of cyberpunk edge run is kind of
like scary as well just the way it was
directed which one was episode six uh so
much scary more so like oh no
oh oh that episode yeah oh yeah I think
it's well it's easily one of the best
episodes in the show oh I think it is
like by Far and Beyond the best episode
in the show I think just like even just
like the last five minutes of it I don't
know incredible yeah I just found the
way that they portrayed cyber psychosis
yeah just I that really like gave me
like an unnerving feeling seeing some of
like your favorite characters like
experience I was like it was cool
because it's like you know normally the
co when you hear about the concept of
cyber psychosis it's [__] terrifying
on the game it's it's dumb as [__] it is
we got another psycho go and gun them
and then you just go and [__] shoot
them and it never happens to you
I think I think what what was so good
about that in cyberpunk was that like
it's yes it's scary but also because you
know about the person that it's
happening to it you also feel really
empty inside of like you just feel sad
and you're like ah [__] hell why yeah
like why why did it come to this kind of
thing and then when you know the that
scene happens you're just left with this
idea of like [__]
now I don't want to watch it anymore
this just made me sad but I'm also gonna
keep watching it yeah yeah I mean did
you all watch it like one day is like as
well because it's just yeah it goes so
[__] yeah on one flight the one that
I was on with you and now oh yeah it was
like broken by the end the guy was like
do you want another cup of tea I was
like yes
and some tissues please
but not I mean yeah I would love to see
more Horror in anime because that's I
do you think there would be any live
action horror films that would work in
anime
yeah yeah yeah so as in like we've seen
a lot of anime been turned into live
action yeah but what if you took an
already pre-existing live-action horror
film yeah do you think it would be as
effective like if you took like say a
ring I'd love like an animated parody of
Paranormal Activity
my leg
the problem with like horror anime is
that to me when I see something animated
it's there's always that suspension of
disbelief that's there you know where I
I there's like a kind of safety zone
where even if some really violent and
gory shit's happening there's always
this disconnect where I'm seeing that oh
okay it's animated therefore it's not
real therefore it's not scary which is
why I rarely find anime horrific unless
it's uniquized dog but like
in terms of like live action horror
that's where that's where I kind of like
draw the line because I can't my brain's
just like oh this is real this has
happened so maybe like something say
like you know because there's a lot of
horror movies like live action movies
that you know use ideas of like sci-fi
and fantasy and stuff like that to like
kind of pose it right but I've always
thought like you know like that's very
far removed from reality so do you think
like if it was well animated enough do
you think that would work like as much
as I don't like the movie right like
yeah what if they took like Cloverfield
and they're like turned it into an anime
no dude
Sharknado
that would be hype to get UFO table on a
shark I can picture it at them jumping
on the [__] sharks and the tornado to
like kill the big shot like super
slow-mo wow
that'd be hype that would be so hype I
would love to see that
yeah oh you do if we get a cyanosaurus
Sharknado yeah I don't know I I've just
I'm happy to be proved wrong but I've
never found a horror specifically horror
anime that has scared me to the point of
a live-action horror yeah I wonder if
that's again yeah but you're mentioning
like just the animated medium is just
inherently less scary yeah yeah yeah and
um I don't know man encourage the
Cowardly Dog was pretty [__] scared
that [__] was terrified that was
animated yeah some of those words red
and Stimpy was pretty scary at times
yeah I mean that's just like [__]
nightmare fuel at some points man holy
[__] how did they get away with some of
this stuff they can do it in western
content so I wonder why they can't do it
now it seems like now that game of
adaptations are all the rage though sure
yeah yeah we had the Super Mario Bros
movie that I haven't seen yet but
apparently it's popping off yeah and
then Castlevania cyberpunk I think uh
last of ours I'm hoping we get more
games
dude I want Doom animated so bad a doom
anime animated by Studio trigger because
we all want to forget about the live
action right oh yes exactly that's what
I'm saying imagine Doom animated it's a
live action that bad yes horrendous like
Resident Evil is god-awful yeah Resident
Evil the movies are campy as [__] yeah
it's like the Mortal Kombat movies you
ever watch those yeah I kind of like no
I like it but it's not a horror film no
it's a [__] stupid ass it's hilarious
comedy movies it's an Adam Sandler film
that somehow thinks it's a horror movie
I remember because the Dude movie has
The Rock in it right it does yeah
immediately I can't take it seriously I
don't know like are you talking about
like the original Mortal Kombat movie I
[__] love that movie yeah but that's
because it's like [__] I watched the
latest one I don't know why I did that
was bad I think the original one had its
own unlike oh my God it has this charms
yes the [__] soundtrack oh my God oh
my God what a [__] classic yeah so
good like that was like the Techno 90s
in a nutshell did you watch the second
one though yeah okay that was bad that
was bad that was actually bad they
literally like cut the budget by like a
millennium as far as I know there's only
good one good one right was the first
one the first one yeah yeah I mean it's
it's good I want to say it's good good
it's like it's fun to watch it's
entertaining it's funny and like it's
like a 90s Mario Bros yeah I'm just it's
just the soundtrack that just goes like
challenge
what did he say is like
some guy good shots Mortal Kombat
oh my [__] god what I want a [__]
hype tune man any fighting games you
think could make good animes
maybe it's basically already that is
basically more like an anime story is
there any fighting games that has a good
story I think the problem is fighting
games have
giant rosters yeah it's like how do you
incorporate them you know well they
tried to do with Mortal Kombat right but
they could only choose a couple of
characters because always as well I
don't know if you feel this way all the
most interesting characters in the
fighting games are like the weird ones
like because you always have the bog
standard characters which are like the
main character dude I want to get like
Mario and Smash Brothers like Mario is
the most boring character in Smash
Brothers dude I want a movie of Kuma
from Tekken
[Music]
cgiate to everyone yeah it's just
cocaine bad
it's just cocaine it is
yeah I want I wanna
oh man man what's the because I feel
like they're gonna make another Mario
movie right because it did well how do
you make the next story
I mean
Yoshi's [__] I mean I haven't seen
the Mario movie but they could
definitely make another Mario movie
right just do like a Mario Galaxy or
like a Mario Sunshine yeah yeah there
are so many Mario characters and that
I'm sure did not get the spotlight I
mean Luigi's Mansion we need a [__]
Luigi's man Warrior [__] or Warrior
World Warrior world [__] yeah man Mario
played by Danny DeVito
that's that's a movie right in itself
has Mario has Mario ever had an anime
uh yes yes
it also had it also had a Saturday
it also has a manga that I used to read
when I was little and it's been still
going for like 40 years